S
THEY DREAM OF ELECTRIC CARS TO
GO TO SLEEP AT NIGHT DREAMING OF
ELECTRIC CARS.
THE REACTION NOW TREAT TRAVIS A
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
JIM JORDAN THEY NEVER WOULD'VE
DONE IT IF IT WAS DONALD TRUMP
IF IT WAS DON JR.'S LAPTOP OR
ERIC TRUMP'S LAPTOP JIM JORDAN.
WEEKS BEFORE AN ELECTION BUT IN
UNISON THEY SANG OUT THE MANTRA
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION YET AGAIN
I GUESS THREE AND A HALF YEARS
OF THAT COLLUSION JUST STUCK IN
THEIR HEAD AND THEY COULDN'T
THINK OF ANYTHING NEW.
>> THIS IS WHY TODAY IS SO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE LEFT LIKES
TO BE ABLE TO LIE ABOUT US AND
WERE NOT ALLOWED TO TELL THE
TRUTH ABOUT THEM.
WE CALL THAT WITH THE EXAMPLE
YOU JUST MENTIONED BIG TECH, BIG
MEDIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY ALL
COLLUDING TO KEEP THE HUNTER
BIDEN STORY FROM WE THE PEOPLE
JUST SAY BEFORE THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELECTION THAT'S
WEATHER SO APOPLECTIC TODAY THE
LEFT IS GOING CRAZY AND AS YOU
POINTED OUT TO GOING CRAZY OVER
AN ELECTRIC CAR MAKER SUPPORTS
FREE SPEECH THAT SHOWS YOU HOW
RIDICULOUS THEY ARE BUT THAT IS
THE POWER THEY HAVE IN THE POWER
THE USE OF 18 MONTHS AGO IN THE
RUN-UP TO THE THE MOST IMPORTANT
ELECTION WE HAVE THE DECIDE WHO
IS HE TO BE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES WAS CAN BE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
THAT IS WHAT TODAY IS SO DARN
SIGNIFICANT.
THE LEFT, LEFT AS A WAY TO SPEAK
YOU DON'T AGREE WITH THEM AND
ALLOWED TO TALK AND IF YOU TRIED
THEY'RE GOING TO ATTACK YOU TRY
TO CANCEL YOU THAT ALL CHANGES
TODAY WITH ELON MUSK NOW OWNING
TWITTER.
>> Hannity: I THINK SO AND
THIS WAS A TWEET FROM ELON MUSK.
HOPE THAT EVEN MY WORST CRITICS
REMAIN ON TWITTER BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT FREE SPEECH MEANS.
BUT SAME US FOREVER.
WHEN EVERY COMEDIAN IN AMERICA
TO FINALLY BE SET FREE FROM
CANCEL CULTURE I'M OFFERING UP
AS A TARGET.
EVERY LIBERAL COMEDIAN TAKE ANY
SHOT YOU WANT TO TAKE SAY
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO SAY I DON'T
CARE I ASK ONE LITTLE FAVOR IN
RETURN JUST BE FUNNY ABOUT IT
SAY WHATEVER YOU WANT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IN FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
COMEDIANS CAN EVEN TELL JOKES
ANYMORE WITHOUT WORRYING ABOUT I
GUESS WITHOUT WEARING ABOUT
SLAPPED IN THE FACE IN THIS
TIME.
>> IT'S A GOOD POINT AND LET'S
ENJOY THE VICTORY THAT WE HAVE
AS OF LATE SEAN.
CNN PLUS LIT $300 MILLION ON
FIRE AND EXPLODED.
WE GOT THAT JUDGE DOWN IN
FLORIDA THINK THE LORD THAT
DONALD TRUMP APPOINTED HER THAT
SHE WAS ABLE TO END THIS MASK
MANDATE AND NOW YOU HAVE A
FULL-FLEDGED LEFT WING LOU
CHECK MARK BRIGADE PANIC BECAUSE
ELON MUSK IS YOU JUST READ THAT
SWEET IS SAYING HEY I BELIEVE IN
FREEDOM OF SPEECH AND IF YOU
WONDERED HOW MUCH OF A RIM JOB
THAT WERE DEALING WITH RIGHT NOW
ON TWITTER SOMEONE COMES IN AND
SAYS I WANT TO HAVE CONTENT
NEUTRAL POLICY THAT ALLOWS A
ROBUST AND UNINHIBITED
MARKETPLACE OF IDEAS TO FLOURISH
IS BEING ATTACKED BY THE LEFT
WING IN THIS COUNTRY.
THEY DON'T WANT AN ACTUAL
MARKETPLACE OF IDEAS THEY DON'T
WANT TO DEBATE IDEAS THEY WANT
TO CANCEL PEOPLE AND TO YOUR
POINT SEAN RIGHT NOW COMICS ARE
TERRIFIED TO DO THEIR COMEDY
MANY PLACES ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES
THE MOST BECAUSE KIDS COME UP ON
STAGE AND SAY HEY I WAS AN
INAPPROPRIATE JOKE WE DIDN'T
ENJOY THIS AND THIS IS WHY WE
HAVE TO DESTROY WHAT I BELIEVE
IS THE TWO TWIN PILLARS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY RIGHT NOW.
IDENTITY POLITICS, AND HE
CANCEL CULTURE, THE COMBINATION
OF THOSE TWO ELON MUSK IS
OPPOSING THEM I THINK WE ALL
NEED TO BE CELEBRATING WITH
GREAT GLEE WHAT IS GOING ON.
>> Hannity: I THINK YOU WILL
THAT STATEMENT WAS PRETTY
POWERFUL I HOPE MY WORST CRITICS
REMAIN ON TWITTER KEEP ATTACKING
ME.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE BEST LINE
THAT HE MADE ALL THROUGHOUT THIS
ATTEMPT TO PURCHASE.
NOW WE KNOW JIM JORDAN THAT
JOE BIDEN LIED WHEN HE SAID OVER
AND OVER AGAIN HE NEVER HAD A
SINGLE CONVERSATION ABOUT
HUNTER'S FOREIGN BUSINESS DEALS
WE HAVE PICTURES WITH JOE BIDEN
AND HUNTER AND SOME OF THOSE
PARTNERS.
WE HAVE ALL THE TEXT MESSAGES
THAT POINT TO JOE BIDEN'S DIRECT
KNOWLEDGE NOW THE QUESTION IS IF
ELON MUSK RAN TWITTER AT THE
TIME AND STAY TRUE TO
FREE SPEECH IT INCENSE
"THE NEW YORK POST" AND LET'S
SAY FACEBOOK DIDN'T DO IT AND
INSTAGRAM DIDN'T DO IT AND LET'S
SAY 200 AND CANCEL DONALD TRUMP
BUT ALLOW THE MOST OF A RANT TO
KEEP THEIR ACCOUNTS FOR WIRE
WOULD THAT HAVE IMPACTED THE
ELECTION IN YOUR VIEW?
>> COURSE IT WILL LOOK AT HOW
THE LEFT CRAZY OVER ONE
PLATFORM.
THE CONTROLS HIGHER EDUCATION
AND HOLLYWOOD.
THEY CONTROL BIG CORPORATIONS TO
CONTROLS THE WHITE HOUSE THE
SENATE AND THE HOUSE AND THEY'RE
GOING CRAZY BECAUSE I CAN LOSE
ONE PART OF ONE OF THOSE JUST
TWITTER THAT SHOWS YOU THE
MONOPOLY THEY HAVE AND WE STILL
ALMOST WANT IMAGINE WHAT
WOULD'VE HAPPENED IF THE TRUTH
OF GOTTEN OUT THERE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WERE JOE BIDEN
SENATE DEBATE I SENT A NOTE
DEALING WITH COMPANIES WITH
CONNECTION OF THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
THERE ARE SO MANY REASONS WHY
THAT'S WRONG BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE HUNTER BIDEN GOT PAID TO
THE CHINESE ENERGY COMPANY CL
WOULD EMIT A HUGE DIFFERENCE.
>> Hannity: YOUR HUGE TAKE ON
AT THIS CAN BE DEEP AND
PROFOUND.
ALL WE WERE ASKING FOR WAS FOR
PEOPLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT IT AND
MAKE A DECISION, THE MEDIA
DEPLETE SUCH A A DEFENSE CLAY
THEY WOULDN'T EVEN ASK THE
QUESTION THEY CAME UP WITH ONE
TALKING POINT IT WAS
REGURGITATED BY EVERYONE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, EVERYONE ON
THE NEWS MEDIA, EVERYONE IN ALL
THESE BIG TECH COMPANIES AND
THAT THIS LOOK LIKE RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION, 51 HIGHLY RANKED
FORMER INTELLIGENCE AGENTS
AGENCY THEY SAID THE SAME THING
TOO WITH NO EVIDENCE THEY JUST
LIED TO US OUTRIGHT.
>> THIS IS WHAT WE NEED
JIM JORDAN AND ALL THE
REPUBLICANS BACK IN POWER IN THE
HOUSE REPRESENTATIVES THIS IS
WHY WE NEED THE SENATE BACK IN
REPUBLICAN CONTROL.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT IF
TWITTER HAD ALLOWED
"THE NEW YORK POST" STORY TO GO
OUT FIRST OF ALL EVERYONE
PROBABLY WOULDN'T HAVE BLOCKED
IT BECAUSE WHAT WE KNOW THAT ALL
THESE BIG TECH COMPANIES COLLUDE
AND AS SOON AS ONE DECIDES OR
THEY WANT A BAND DONALD TRUMP
EVERYONE DID.
AS SOON AS ONE SAID YOU COULDN'T
READ "THE NEW YORK POST" STORY
EVERYONE DID.
SEAN EVEN WITH THE NUMBERS THAT
ARE OUT OF 20,000 PEOPLE HAD
CHANGED THEIR VOTE IN 2,020 IN
WISCONSIN AND GEORGIA, AND IN
ARIZONA THAT'S ONE NHL ARENA,
THAT'S ONE MBA ARENA THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY 20,000 PEOPLE IN THOSE
THREE STATES DONALD TRUMP AS
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES RIGHT
NOW.
YOU CANNOT CONVINCE ME THAT
TWITTER'S DECISION WAS IN ITS
RIGHT COLLUSIVE BENEFIT TO THE
JOE BIDEN CAMPAIGN THAT ECHOED
ACROSS ALL SOCIAL MEDIA AND THIS
IS WHY IT'S SO BIG I WAS
OVERCOME AND UNDER SHOW AND ALL
THE DEMOCRATS WATCHING HER
WATCHING HIM INSTEAD OF MSNBC
THE SET OF CNN AND THAT'S WHAT
THE DATA REFLECTS.
THERE ARE DESPERATE DEMAND IN
TRUTH AND AUTHENTICITY IN THIS
COUNTRY AND FOX NEWS SERVES IT
AND I HOPE THAT ELON MUSK FOR
PURPOSES OF BIG SOCIAL MEDIA CAN
SERVE THAT SAME MARKETPLACE THAT
IS DESPERATE FOR TRUTH AND
HONESTY AND I THINK IF HE STICKS
TO HIS GUNS THIS IS GONNA BE A
MONUMENTAL MOMENT THE BIGGEST
WIN FOR FREE SPEECH AND THE
21ST CENTURY IS ELON MUSK BUYING
TWITTER IN MY OPINION.
>> Hannity: IT'S CAN BE
INTERESTING TO WATCH FOR SURE,
JIM JORDAN THE LAST QUESTION.
WE KNOW THAT YOU CAN'T MAKE
THREATS AGAINST INDIVIDUALS OR
THREATENED VIOLENCE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA NOR SHOULD YOU BE
ABLE TO.
NOW FOR YOU GO THROUGH MY
SPEECH?
WOULD HE DO OVERTLY RACIST
PEOPLE ANTI-SEMITIC LANGUAGE
THAT PEOPLE USE?
WHICH OF THE RULES BE IN YOUR
VIEW?
>> YOU ERR ON THE SIDE OF THE
FIRST MOMENT WITH THE
FIRST AMENDMENT IT IS SERVED OUR
NATION WHILE YOU ERR ON THAT
SIDE RIGHT THERE THIS IS ONE
THING THAT WERE LOOKING AT IT IS
IN FACT THE PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT
COUNTRY THAT GIVES THE MAJORITY
LOOKING AT HOW WE CHANGE AND
EXECUTE HOW WE REFORM IT WOULD
BE DO?
BUT IF YOU CAN AIR YOU ERR ON
THE SIDE OF THE FOR THE MOMENT
FREE SPEECH IS FIVE RIGHTS UNDER
THE FIRST A